لنتوقف مع سلام خضر
وخارطة
القصه تتركز فيما جرى في حي الشجاعيه في
وسط او في شمال قطاع غزه الشجاعيه هو احد
المداخل الرئيسيه المدخل الشرقي لمدينه
غزه في احدى ايام القتال تحديدا ليله ال
21 من الشهر الحالي وقعت معارك قويه
وعنيفه جدا في حي الشجاعيه الذي جرى هو ان
هناك ارتباك ميداني بشكل عام شهدته مناطق
شمال القطاع من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي وصلت
الى مراحل ان الجنود كانوا يتوغلون داخل
المناطق الشماليه ويشكون للقياده بان هناك
انقطاع في الاتصالات المباشره بينهم وبين
القياده ولكن لواء جولاني وهو الذي يعرف
بانه من قوات نخبه المشاد في الجيش
الاسرائيلي هو في الحقيقه راس حربه يسمى
او يصف بانه راس حربه اي معركه بريه شارك
في جميع الحروب التي خاضتها اسرائيل من
اجتياح لبنان الى الحروب المتعاقبه في
قطاع غزه في تلك الليله دخلت مجموعه من
الجنود الى حي الشجاعيه ا وهذ هؤلاء
الجنود كانوا يشتبهون بوجود شيء في احد
المباني اربعه منهم توغلوا الى
داخل احد الشوارع ودخلوا الى احد المباني
عند دخولهم قامت كتائب القسام بتفجير جزء
من المبنى علقوا في الداخل قاموا بطلب
النجده اتت قوه ثانيه مؤله لمسانده هؤلاء
الجنود ولكن لم عندما وصلت القوه المؤله
ايضا استهدفتها كتائب القسام وتمكنت من
قطل قطع الاتصال اللس بشكل كامل بين هذه
المجموعه وبين المجموعات الاخرى التي كانت
تتمركز في نقاط عند مداخل حي
الشجاعيه عندما انقطع الاتصال قائد احد
احدى السرايا الذي كان متمركزا في واحده
من هذه النقاط تواصل مع القياده وطلب دعما
جويا القياده وهنا نعني القياده العليا في
قياده جولاني وليس بالضروره تلك المتوغلة
طلب دعما بالطيران القياده ابلغته بانه لا
يمكن الاغاره على منطقه الشجاعيه خشيه من
ان يكون جميع الجنود ما زالوا على قيد
الحياه وداخل المبنى ثم قام القائد الاعلى
الموجود في شمال القطاع
الذي حل مكان القائد الاساسي للواء 13 في
جولاني الذي قتل عند بدايه المعارك اتخذ
قرارا بارسال كبار ق السرايا الموجودين
معه في الموقع لتبيان حقيقه الوضع
الميداني وعندما وصلت المجموعه الثالثه
وكان من ضمنها مجموعات انقاذ انقضت عليهم
كتائب القسام خاضت معركه استمرت لاكثر من
ساعتين ونصف باعتراف الجيش الاسرائيلي في
تلك الليله قتل تسعه من جنود لواء جولاني
في هذه المعركه فقط ومن هنا نفهم مذا تحدث
الذي تحدث عنه الياس كرام مراسل الجزيره
عندما قال بان الاقاله كانت
لان قائد السريه كان يرفض ارسال الجنود
الى داخل المباني هذه الحادثه نتوقع ان
تكون حدثت بعد الكمائن المتتاليه في ليله
واحده التي اوقعتها كتائب القسام بلواء
جولاني في اليوم
التالي صدر القرار باخراج لواء جولاني من
او او الكتيبه 13 من لواء جولاني من قطاع
غزه وقالت اسرائيل في حينه انهم سيخرجون
لنيل بعض الراحه وعندما خرج لواء جولاني
كان القتال لا يزال مستمرا
وعنيفا وفي ايامه الاولى في جنوب قطاع غزه
كان الجيش الاسرائيلي يحاول التوغل الاعمق
الى خان يونس اطر عندها الى دعم الجنود
الموجودين هناك بوحده كثير وهي ايضا من
نخبه المشاه ليصبح هناك خمسه الويه تقاتل
وبهذا قد نكون وضعنا في السياق الاقاله
التي جرت جمال هذه ابرز طبعا الاحداث مع
لواء جولاني والاحداث كثيره في قطاع غزه